hey everyone deavolo here and in today's
video we're going to be going over the
most intense arc of tokyo avengers yet
so many insane things happen throughout
this arc that it's actually hard to put
a finger on what my favorite moment
could possibly be this arc honestly ends
on such a climactic point and leaves you
wondering what could possibly come next
this here is the tenjiku arc but just
before we get into today's video if you
do enjoy my content and want to keep up
to date with the latest tokyo avengers
and just other anime content in general
then make sure you hit that subscribe
button and also be sure to leave a like
on the video as it really helps out with
the algorithm and pushes my stuff to a
bunch of new amazing people also if you
aren't fully caught up on the tokyo
avengers story then be sure to check out
my video on the entire tokyo avengers
story explained as it explains the
entire story and even contains this
specific video i just wanted to break
that video down into a three-part series
for people who are just specifically
keen to watch those later arcs but
anyway enough of that crack open a coke
sit back and relax as this is going to
be one absolutely jam-packed video
emma's mother tells her that she has to
go somewhere far away and leaves emma at
her grandfather's house this was the
last time emma ever saw her mother
as emma watches her grandfather's
martial arts class shinochiro walks by
and compliments bhaji on his fighting
skills bhaji says that emma sounds like
a foreigner's name which mikey agrees
baji then dubs himself as ed short for
edward to match emma's foreign name and
mikey sano at the time dubs himself
mikey short for michael they run around
the dojo playing and joking around in
the midst of this emmer admits allowed
that she knows her mother hates her as
it is why she abandoned her even though
she knows this she cannot stop herself
from missing her in the present emma
reflects that she has never felt lonely
from that time on smiling she walks
towards draken who has been waiting for
her outside somewhere else takuya
remarks that he has to use the restroom
as his stomach hurts akun says that he
has to go as well
just as yamagishi tells shifuyu that
they got jumped by another gang the same
gang members exit a train in front of
takamichi bringing out a base in akun
they ask him if takamichi is atonement
member as well
one of the gang members tells takamichi
that he will become the fifth time and
victim before he can begin his assault
shifuyu runs up and kicks him saving
takamichi he tells tokomichi to run
before long shifuyu is knocked out by a
gang member who declares that they will
slaughter tomen winnecon regains
consciousness he reveals that there are
300 tenjuku members in tokyo takamishi
realizes shifuyu will be in trouble he
tells akun and the others to go to
tomen's hideout while he goes to help
shifuyu as he runs hoping for shifuy
safety he is ambushed by tenjuku
suddenly akun appears kicking one of
tokumichi's attackers in surprise
takamichi realizes that akun yamagashi
and makoto followed him they tell
takamichi that they will help him as he
is their captain
though they fight earnestly they are
outnumbered and overpowered a tenjiku
member acclaims their victory as he lies
on the ground exhausted takamichi
wonders about the motive and origin of
tenjuku as he has never heard or
encountered them before from the crowd
of tenjuku members kisaki steps forward
approaching takamichi he speculates that
takamichi has no idea what's going on
and announces that the beginning of the
kanto uprising is beginning kisaki
announces to takamichi that he is now
the general staff officer of tenjuku a
yokohama gang as the tenjuku members
surround takamichi and his friends two
bikes suddenly arrive mowing down the
panicked group on one of the bikes
someone hutakamichi recognizes as smiley
the fourth division captain arrives with
an unconscious takuya takamichi is
confused until smiley pulls him up onto
the bike yamageshi explains that smiley
has a twin nicknamed angry who was the
vice captain of the fourth division the
twins take shifuyu and takamichi to raid
yokohama to counter-attack tenjiku after
they noticed two tenjiku members smiley
and angry prepare to gather information
about tenjuku's hideout from them
takamichi remarks that their method of
gathering information is more like
torture takamichi tells shifuyu that he
met kasaki who joined tenjiku and he now
believes that kisaki's goal is to create
a tormund that is convenient for him
coming from the future to achieve his
goal if kisaki is a time leaper he is
now desperate as he was killed by mikey
in the future and can no longer return
until he can change the future however
shifu says that they have to find out if
kisaki is truly a time leaper takamichi
shifuyu smiley and angry find tenjiku's
hideout in a warehouse where a great
number of tenjuku members are waiting
for them they realize that they have
been led into a trap a tensioku member
steps forward indicating that they have
been waiting when takamichi asks the
leader of the group how many tenjuku
members they are facing he replies that
there are a hundred unexpectedly he
orders all of them to leave the tenjiku
member introduces himself as kakucho one
of tenjiku's big four and smiley swings
a punch just before smiley gains the
upper hand kokuto grins smiley knocks
down kokucho by diving at him with his
legs outstretched as kokucho lies on the
ground smiley tells him that he is as
strong as he expected taiju's big four
to be as the group prepares to go back
to tokyo takamichi says that kokucho
seems familiar takamichi realises that
kokucho was his elementary school friend
takamiji tells kokucho he has not
changed at all and still picks fights
when much kikuchi responds that
takamichi has not changed either calling
him his hero he tells takamichi that he
has devoted himself to izana kudokawa
now tenjiku's boss in essence he is now
enemies with takamichi laser at tommen's
emergency meeting takamichi continues to
ponder kisaki's role draken announces
the commencement of the meeting tomon
members were attacked in various parts
of tokyo all by tenjiku members the
first division is called up to explain
their experience with shifuyu explaining
that the group who attacked them was
called team mochizuki matsuya disputes
mochi's role as tenjiku's main force
telling them that the hatani brothers
were also part of tenjiku draken adds
that the other tomen members were also
attacked by shion matarame these
delinquents are all part of the infamous
s62 generation a generation with
significantly brutal and powerful
delinquents mike kendrick introduced
that because the s62 generation would
not usually team up they must have deep
connections with tomen mikey pledges to
fight against tenjiku and plans to
invade yokohama
arriving at tachibana's door takamichi
vows to go back as many times as it
takes to change the future just then
hina arrives home asking if takamichi
has been fighting again as he looks back
to the time he swore to save hina
takamichi smiles saying he keeps on
losing after takamichi informs naoto of
his suspicions of kisaki's time-leaping
abilities naoto says that kisaki must be
killed as killing him is the only way to
ensure a guild future unexpectedly naoto
then says he is joking naoto explains
that izana is now one of tommen's top
members a former leader of the black
dragons as naoto plans to investigate
izana through the police network
takamichi decides to investigate as well
takamichi ends up going to the church
where the christmas conflict took place
a man in a neighboring pew asks him to
be quiet and continues his prayer this
person turns out to be taiju who reveals
that hikai has passed away he tells
takamichi that the old members of tomen
are all dead as he has found a survivor
that may give information about tomen's
past takamichi requests to talk to taiji
about izana and the black dragons
takamichi introduces naoto to taiju
taiju brings them to his restaurant and
tells them that although he has no
intention of collaborating with police
he has a connection with tomen because
of his brother takamichi asks why izana
joined tomen after becoming the leader
of the black dragons in which taju tells
him that he is the order wrong he
reveals that shinichirosano founded the
black dragons and each generation
flourished until izana became the 8th
generation leader because of this izana
is older than taiju as he is part of the
s62 generation like the others in
tenjiku as he realizes that kisaki made
his own way back into toumen takamichi
is confused as kisaki is dead in the
future taju asks if kisaki is verifiably
dead which prompts nyato to reveal that
izana used his influence over the police
to fake kisaki's death because maki is
dead and kisaki is overseas izana is
effectively thomann's leader just then
koku enters along with inupi and
numerous gang members inyape reveals
that they are there to abduct all three
of them on the order of izana taiju
tells takamichi inerotu to escape
through the back asking naoto to
investigate hakai's death as he and
naoto run along an alleyway taking me
she thinks about what taijo said to
enyupa and koko suddenly he is face to
face with the barrel of a gun pointed by
kisaki as kisaki orders takamichi to die
naoto suddenly shoves takamichi out of
the line of sight of fire sustaining the
bullet himself as takamishi cradles a
gravely wounded naoto kisaki remarks on
the carelessness of naoto's attempt to
save takamichi izana tells takomichi and
naoto that they killed his monkey
leaving takamichi confused he then
orders kokucho to kill takamichi as he
lays on the ground dying after being
shot takamuchi apologizes to naoto naoto
reflects that when they first met he was
filled with despair not wanting to put
all his trust in someone as pathetic as
takamichi he was dumbfounded as to why
hina would fall in love with him but
after witnessing takamichi's numerous
failures he believes takamichi is a hero
never giving up regardless as he reaches
out for what he considers their last
handshake he tells takamichi he is proud
of them with both of them tearing up now
to remarks that death is terrifying as
they clasp hands takamichi swears to not
let their handshake be the last
believing that he will never give up
after his time left takamichi rushes to
the tachibana household he meets naoto
outside and desperately shakes his hand
however takamichi shakes his hand to no
avail he cannot time leap to the future
meaning that his trigger in the future
naoto is currently dead grief stricken
takamichi sits at the bottom of a
playground slide he concludes that he
will always fail declaring he is better
off dead suddenly haena appears behind
him on his slide bumping into him gently
she tells takamichi that she loves him
he realizes that he mistook his shadow
for neyotos and she has heard everything
that he has just said hina asks
takamichi's actual age and he replies
that he is 26 she says that she will
only ask one more question has takamichi
propose to her in the future
takamichi admits that he has not yet but
he blurts out that he thinks it would be
nice if they got married much to his own
shock when hina asks if that served as a
proposal takamichi answers yes haena
responds that she can now die happy with
his motivation renewed takamichi deduces
that the enemy is izana kurokawa
takamichi decides his present goal is to
find out why mikey will trust izana at
the sano household mikey arrives and
takamichi explains that the leader of
tenjiku is a person named izana kurokawa
mikey reveals that he has met izani
before
draken speculates that izana may be
connected to shinochito as he was a
former black dragon's leader revealing
to takamichi that shinichiro founded the
black dragons but tells takamichi to
keep this fact a secret draken concludes
that izana the 8th generation leader was
the cause of the black dragon's
degradation in reveals that he is her
older brother much the shock of everyone
else emma explains that the last time
she saw her brother was right before he
was institutionalized takamichi realizes
that his honor desired to defeat mikey
draken suspects that the black dragon's
attack on kazutura was part of izana's
plan to defeat mikey because he held a
personal grudge against him takamichi
calls shifuyu over to his place and
informs him of the information he
gathered at mikey's house
just as he announces the start of his
strategy meeting a honk outside
interrupts them the car window rolls
down revealing the fifth division
captain mucho stepping out of the car
miksha greets takamichi as shifuyu tells
takamichi to watch out tomin's fifth
division steps up restraining all of
takamichi's friends leaving him without
any allies as sakamichi asks what's
going on mucho repeatedly punches him in
the face with tokumichi barely
unconscious he hears mucho mention that
izana is giving him busy work taking
which he finds inupi and koko beason and
restrained to cheers enyupay explains to
a confused takamichi that mucho has been
allied with izana all along as he is
part of the es62 generation mucho pulls
a chair up and explains that the tomen's
fifth division has a unique role serving
as the special task division which
enables them to engage in in fighting
calling the fifth division the public
morality council mucho says that the
fifth division serves to punish tommen's
traitors even without mikey's permission
and yapay speculates that mucho believes
takamichi is a spy for tenjiku and
brought him and koko into tomin as part
of this military responds that they are
getting worked up over a
misunderstanding and recalls that he
nizana committed crimes together then
formed different gangs and became known
as the s62 generation
however izana stopped in gang activity
leaving mikey to recruit him into tomen
he explains to takamichi that he is a
founding member of tenjiku takamichi
asks mucho what he is trying to
accomplish mucho explains that koko is a
valuable asset as he has an aptitude for
money making leaving him desirable to
izana mucho plans to kill inyupay and
takamichi which will force koko to join
tenjiko muchu offers to spare any pay
and takamichi if koko agrees to join
tenjiku however takamichi tells koko
that he should not obey mucho when mucho
remarks that takamichi has no chance of
winning a fight against him although he
was still restrained takamichi charged
mucho after being unconscious for a
while taking which he finds himself atop
a pile of garbage along with inyupay
remembering what transpired and their
fight against mucho after hearing
takamichi's words anyappei tells him
that he will help takamichi fight mucho
as they rush it mucho he remarks to koko
that they will die unless he chooses to
join ten jihu
just as mucho prepares to punch inupei
koko begs for him to stop promising to
do whatever is required of him
at a time in meeting between mikey and
the members of the first division enya
paid chuckles to himself remarking that
he never thought he would wear tommen's
uniform after mikey learns of mucho's
betrayal takamichi vows that the first
division will devote itself to rescuing
koko mikey asks and you pay when he
suspects tenjuki will stage their attack
in your pay stays tomorrow on february
the 22nd mikey orders them to gather all
of toman for a pep rally in preparation
meanwhile kokucho forcefully tells izana
he disagrees with his plan asking why he
would trust hanuman kisaki izana tells
him to shut up as he sees no other way
to defeat tomin draken announces that
tenjiku will attack tourman today they
need to put forth their best effort as
tenjiku will likely fight underhandedly
hakai angrily demands tomen to do the
same explaining that matsuya and smiley
were victims of a motorcycle attack
leaving them unconscious and
hospitalized just then payan revs his
bike telling them to shut up he remarks
that they are cowardly for fearing
defeat though he understands how akai
feels after the attack on matsuya he
tells them to look at mikey as he is not
smiling mikey acknowledges that all the
captains cannot help during this battle
but they can rely on him
with their confidence renewed tomin vows
to crush tenjiku when morning comes
takamichi and inyape visit shinachiro's
grave when anipe declares takamichi as
the 11th leader of the black dragons
soon after izana approaches them however
takamichi does not recognize him until
in your pace screams izana's name
grabbing him and demanding to know what
he is doing with koko isana calmly
reminds him that koko chose to join
tenjiku and he is just here to visit his
brother's grave he tells inyupei that he
does not care about him anymore as he
now has koko behind them mikey who is
with emma tells inyupay to let go he
orders takamichi to leave with emma
meanwhile hanma sits upon a motorcycle
remarking to kisaki that this is
uncharacteristic of him to get his hands
dirty holding a bat kisaki responds that
he cannot leave this deed to anyone else
from a distance emery takamichi watched
the graveyard she asks aloud why do boys
have to fight all the time saying that
mikey has always retained a strong
exterior as a gang leader however she
says he is just a child unable to sleep
without his old blanket emma vows to
save mikey just like how he saved her
takamichi realizes that emma's the only
person who can understand and support
mikey emma asks takamichi if he wants a
drink from the vending machine as he
tries to remember if emma exists in the
future kisaki and hanma ride towards
them after takamichi and emma buy their
drinks they see a motorcycle riding
straight towards him in the passenger
seat kisaki screams as he speeds past
takamichi narrowly avoiding him and
strikes emma with a bear still
processing what just occurred takamichi
sees emma on the ground in shock he
realizes kisaki was targeting emma
before driving away kisaki tells
takamichi that it is over as he cradles
emma's motionless body he realizes
everything he has tried to change thus
far has been for nothing as emma is the
key to saving mikey
crying he begs her to wake up as he can
not save her if she dies in the past
hearing the commotion maki approaches
them and sees emma on the ground mikey
asks what happened in takami she
explains that emma was hit in a drive-by
biker attack perpetrated by tessa kasaki
mikey tells takamichi to set emma on his
back as they walk to the hospital maggie
asks if she remembers the last time he
carried her when she was five she broke
her leg chasing him emma begins to
instruct mikey on what to do if
something happens to her requesting
mikey to tell dracon that she loves him
as her eyes well up with tears emma
tells a crying takamichi to take care of
mikey for her just before her body
slumps and death
panicked mikey tries to reveal to emma
that draken has mutual feelings for her
telling her that he will call him as
soon as they reach the hospital and
hopes that she will wake up however she
does not respond trembling mikey tells
takamichi to put his jacket over her as
she is getting cold
mikey is silent when draken asks what
happened he angrily punches mike in the
face demanding as to why he let this
happen takamichi begins to reason with
dracon
telling him to overcome and accept the
events however he realizes the absurdity
of this as he has been unable to accept
hina's death himself defeated takamichi
knows he cannot reverse this fate as
tomin awaits their leader at the shrine
they wonder what is going on just then
inupi pulls up on his motorcycle
informing them of the events
at the hospital mikey is still in his
catatonic state having lost the will to
fight takamichi vows to fight tenjiku
even if he has to face them alone shifu
meets takamichi outside of the hospital
bringing him to the shrine where tomen
is waiting they announced that emma has
died in an accident which means that
neither mikey nor draken will be able to
fight however he insists that they fight
tenjiku tonight which angers tomen
causing them to turn their backs on him
having originally planned to fight alone
he tells shifu that he is going to fight
tenjiku even if he has to do so alone
shifu offers to fight alongside him
though he expects both of them to die at
tenjuku's hands just then akun exclaims
to takamechi that he is going to fight
with him as well as takamichi never runs
away from a fight prompting yamagishi
makoto and takuya all to agree to fight
with them
shifuyu tells tomen that although the
odds are against them running away would
ensure the end of tomen leaving them
with no choice but to fight this rolls
up tomon as they chant in support
takamichi tells shifuyu that he wants to
save emma and baji as well believing
nothing is impossible not long after
footsteps announced toman's arrival led
by shifuyu and takamichi hisaki tells
takamichi that he has been waiting once
again calling him hiro izana points out
tommen's disadvantage in the battle as
tenjiku outnumbers tomen 450
he calls up shion as their forerunner
payon steps up telling shion to face him
he reminds takamechi that he is the
acting president of the third division
xion interrupts payan saying that he can
defeat all of tomen alone unexpectedly
payen knocks out xion with a single
punch after this with takamichi as the
acting leader tomin charges at tenjiku
to begin their fight takamichi shouts to
kisaki and they both agree to settle
their battle tonight izana watches the
battle he remarks that he is impressed
he stomps on shion's unconscious face
remarking that the black dragons lost to
mikey because of shion's weakness
although he says he does not usually
engage in revenge isana asks payan to
fight him when payan eagerly charges
towards him isana kicks him in the face
knocking him out with a single blow
shocked takamishi realizes izana's true
strength
as takamichi charges at kikucho he is
easily thrown to the ground kokucho
tells him he is weak asking if he is
just talk takamichi tells him to let him
fight kisaki hokutru tells him that he
will stand as an obstacle until he is
defeated seeing takamichi on the ground
shifuyu rushes to assist him but he is
blocked by mochi who punches him telling
him not to be distracted
meanwhile anya pay tells mucho to move
as he wants to talk to koko just as he
says this mucho easily overpowers nup
as nup cries out in pain mucho sits atop
him telling inupay that he is defeated
hikai and angry attempt to back each
other up in their fight against rindo
and ran winikai asks angry says his arm
may be broken brendo mocks this telling
angry he will break another additional
limb watching this shifu says that since
they are both the baby of the family
they are used to being pampered amid
hakai in angry's argument the hatani
brothers knock both of them to the
ground mocking them for depending on
their older siblings
laying on the ground hakai and angry
look for their siblings once again but
conclude that it cannot be helped they
realise they shared weaknesses and
reliance on others this motivates their
drive to fight standing up they prepare
to face the hatani brothers once again
charging towards them brundu and ran
their brothers easily bring the duo to
the ground as angry remarks his older
brother would have avoided rondo's
tackle rindo grabs a hold of his left
leg breaking it as angry cries out in
pain as angry crawls barely able to move
angry watches desperately as rindu grabs
zakai's arm while ran hits his face with
a baton he believes that hikai will die
from their relentless attacks and begins
crying begging the brothers to stop
meanwhile smiley tells matsuya that
angry is a good person beating up others
doesn't come naturally to him however he
adds when angry starts crying his nature
changes as he has the limits that cause
the ogre to come out facing the hitani
brothers a crying angry tells them that
they went too far
apologizing to his older brother for
breaking his promise both ran and rendo
are surprised to find angry standing as
his leg was broken smiley tells matsuya
that as the crying blue ogre their angry
is over 100 times stronger than himself
brendo eagerly tackles angry however
much to his surprise angry does not
budge
angry tells him that he last cried
during his fourth year of elementary
school his brother told him not to cry
again as he would become a murderer if
he did so angry knocks out rindo in a
single punch much to the shock of
everyone around them the tenjiku members
witnessed this with confusion causing
mochi to abandon his fight with shifuyu
to fight angry
putting his arm around angry mochi
remarks that he can beat him alone just
before angry slams mochi's head into the
ground with a punch
as he cries angry asks the fearful
tenshiku members who is next mucho steps
up simultaneously they grab each other's
arms however angry overpowers mucho
slamming him onto the ground as any pay
shifuyu angry takamichi and hikai stand
up believing that they have the
advantage mucho stands up remembering an
order izana relayed to him swinging
their blade mucho announces that he has
no intention to lose just before he
stabs takamichi kokucho stands between
them grabbing mucho's blade kukucho
punches him telling mucho that he does
not want him to be ruined by tenjiku
confused takamichi and his friends
wonder if kokucho is their ally kokuto
tells takamichi that he is not the same
person he knew in elementary school
kokuto quickly dispatches angry shifuyu
and inyupay as he watches izani remarks
that the other heavenly kings are
useless in comparison with most of
tomen's members exhausted and defeated
kokucho tells takamechi that now he
comprises tomin facing kokucho takamichi
tells him that although he has gotten
stronger he is now a member of a brutal
criminal organization
standing over india pay coco remarks
that takamichi as well as inyapay's
dreams for the black dragons will be
easily defeated
shifuyu unable to move panics about
takamichi's safety
takamichi gets up again remarking that
kucho has not changed as he still
punches like he did when he was a child
justice inyupay tells koko that
takamichi will never lose kokucho tells
him to prepare to die punching him again
just as kokucho prepares to deliver his
final blow shifuyu leaps in between the
two crying he implores takamichi to
accept defeat as no one from tomen is
left standing if tokumichi continues
fighting he will die with his face
swollen and bloody takamichi screams
insisting that tomen will never be
defeated as long as he is there
in reaction kisaki tells kokucho to move
over asking if takamichi has the
determination to win even if he dies
kisaki points a gun at his head
takamichi reflects back on his lack of
fear as the encouragement and
self-sacrifice of countless people
after takamichi asks kisaki what is
holding him back a shot rings out
however kizaki cannot bring himself to
kill takamichi shooting him in the foot
instead takamichi vows not to give up
even at the cost of his death as kisaki
holds a gun to takamiji's head
threatening to kill him takamichi eggs
him on telling him it should be easy
since he has already killed emma in
response hisaki pulls away his gun and
punches takamichi in the face
just then akun grabs him supporting him
to stand he reminds takamichi that he is
not the type to give up shifuyu tells
takamichi that he is glad he took over
bhaji's role turning to kisaki he says
that although he wants revenge for
bhaji's death their battle should not
become fatal
his psyche angrily retorts that their
resolve does not change the fact that
tomen is losing he then proposes that
tenchiku and tobin merge under tommen's
name upon hearing this takamichi punches
kisaki in the face telling him that he
will beat him up until he understands
takamichi prepares to punch him once
again
however izana blocks his punch telling
hisaki to move out of the way as he will
kill all of tomon takamichi tries to
think of a reason as to why mikey would
turn evil he concludes that tenjiku's
influence caused mikey's downfall
tearfully he swears to protect mikey
just as he is about to punch izana
takamichi suddenly stops having detected
someone's arrival
raising his fist in the air he asks what
took mikey so long he then reminds
everyone of his promise not to lose
everyone is astounded by mikey's
appearance as takamishi cries tears of
relief monkey hugs him thanking him
however takamichi is still concerned
about mikey as he should not be in the
right mental state just then the sound
of draken's motorcycle signals his
arrival as takamichi questions why both
of them are here hina is revealed to be
with them earlier after takamichi left
the hospital pena requested to talk with
a distraught monkey
anna confesses that takameji is trying
to save a lot of people at once she
explains that she will die in 12 years
and that takamichi came from the future
to save her
though they may not believe her
takamichi's palable desperation confirms
this crying hina says that although
takamichi wants to save everyone she is
powerless to help him
this brings mikey and draken out of
their despair as they remember the
numerous times takamichi tried to save
tomen
mikey asks the tenkiku members if they
are handicapped prompting them to
angrily tell mikey and drakken that they
are the ones who are handicapped
demanding that the situation be taken
more seriously mikey responds that
tenjiku are the ones that should take
them more seriously declaring that he
can take down 20 000 men turning to
kisaki izana remarks that his plan
probably did not go as expected suddenly
izana rushes towards mikey landing a
kick on his face just then mikey
releases his signature kick however
izana blocks it just before
complimenting mikey on his skills after
this happens a third time takamichi
realizes the true strength of izana
isana says that despite mikey's
impressive fighting prowess his moves
are easy to read much to everyone's
shock
just as izana punches mikey once more
mikey asks why he killed their sister he
tells mikey he plans to kill all of
tomen and shape a distraught mikey into
shinichiro when maki asks if that is the
reason he killed emma izana responds by
delivering a kick that throws maki onto
the ground
standing over him izana says that mikey
took everything away from him so he must
kill him
while mikey blocks his honors kicks he
tells izana he is wrong as they both
still have a brother after mikey tells
izana that he wants to save him isana
angrily tells him to shut up kicking him
however mikey avoids the attack
remarking to izana that he is starting
to miss he then punches and kicks izana
in succession bringing him to the ground
izani remarks that he is finally
enjoying the fight as mikey's power
poses a formidable challenge mikey
dodges izana's punch and instead strikes
izana in the chest as he rushes towards
mikey with his fist mikey punches him
isana recoils from the attack and
visualizes shinichiro and emma standing
with mikey when mikey tells izana he
lost he screams grabbing kisaki's gun
and pointing it at mikey mikey asks
izana if he will lose everything after
he loses the fire
crying izana thinks back to his mother
who abandoned him with tears in her eyes
she told izana to stay strong despite
his solitude upon seeing izana points a
gun at mikey takamichi calls out telling
izana that using a gun is cheap izana
tells mikey to die but mikey is unfazed
iggy anizana telling him to shoot
an anxious draken implores mikey to be
careful as izana seems serious mikey
continues screaming at his honor to
shoot but just then kokucho slaps the
gun out of izana's hand telling izana to
accept kinjiku's loss angrily izana
demands if kakucho his servant is giving
advice to him a king shaykhi nizana
kokucho tells him that none of tenjuku's
members can win their battles loudly
repeating that tenjiku has lost azizana
screams for him to shut up kisaki
suddenly shoots kikucho in the chest
splattering blood on izana's face and
remarking that he is annoying when
kikucho lunges akisaki kisaki fires his
gun telling kikucho to die
unexpectedly izana leaps in front of the
stream of bullets protecting kokutsu
through the shock of everyone including
kasaki who falls to the ground in
surprise
lying on the ground kokuchu asks izana
what he is doing next to him izana tells
him that his body just moved on its own
as he is dying izana says he wants to
tell mikey something he remarks that
tenchiku has lost and kikucho tells him
that he does not have to say it as it
has already been announced crying
kikuchu asks izana why he protected him
as he is worthless while izana is a king
who wanted to build a new era izana
corrects him telling kukucho that it was
this era smiling he says that kakucho is
the only person he has izana asks mikey
if he wanted to save him and mikey
responds saying that he did as izana is
his brother izana reveals to mikey that
he is not blood related to anyone crying
he tells mikey that there is no way to
save him and as he dies he utters emma's
name poncin izana's motionless body
kikucho cries grasping his hand he tells
izana that he will not be alone in death
as he will be joining him soon upon
seeing kikucho and izan emotionless
mikey announces the end of the tomen
tenjuku dispute turning his attention to
kisaki mikey tells him he will never be
forgiven
just then hana rides up on his
motorcycle grabbing kisaki and escaping
as takamichi powerly watches them right
away draken tells takamichi to get on
his bike to chase them down as he and
takamichi gain ground on hama and kisaki
draken vows to catch them on hanuman's
bike kisaki implores him to drive faster
suddenly hanuma loses control of the
bike throwing him and kisaki to the
ground when hisaki looks up he finds
takamichi standing over him kisaki
instantly runs away and when takamichi
tries chasing him the pain of his foot
overwhelms him dracon pulls him up
ordering takamichi to get on his back
just then hammer catches up to the pier
swinging a metal pipe at draken although
drakken counters the attack he is now
preoccupied with fighting hanma as
takamichi chases kisaki around the
corner hisaki attacks his head with a
brick but takamichi punches kisaki
response takaminshi ends up chasing
kisaki into a parking lot where they
punch each other in quick succession as
they both catch their breath takamichi
notes that he recognizes the area
takamichi tells kisaki to give up and
accept their loss saying that all he
does is manipulate and use others unable
to do anything by himself while he
budding takamichi kasaki explains that a
perfect plan is the way to achieve his
goals as takamichi leaps upon kisaki he
asks if the perfect plan was intended to
defeat him they wrestle in the parking
lot with kisaki ending up on top he
angrily says that he is supposed to be
the dark hero strangling takamechi
kisaki says that all his plans started
perfectly but there was someone who
always ruined them takamichi kicks
kisaki away from him he explains that he
remembers when he was last at the
parking lot standing in front of a fire
he had sworn to become the top of tomin
takamichi tells kisaki that the parking
lot was where hisaki killed henry in the
future he tells kisaki that they will
settle their time living battle upon
hearing this kisaki remarks that his
suspicions are confirmed takamichi is a
time leaper suddenly a scene depicting
kisaki and heine appears in takamichi's
mind takamichi asks what kisaki's
involvement with hina is as he killed
hina in every timeline hearing this
kisaki solemnly says that he failed
visualizing the future scene takamichi
sees kisaki proposing to hina however
she apologizes turning him down before
takamichi can finish comprehending this
kisaki points a gun at him telling
takamichi that their fate ends now
pointing his gun at takamichi kasaki
demands to know why takamichi always
thwarts his plans and how many times he
has leaped when takamichi asks if he
killed hina after her rejections this
enrages kisaki who insists that hina
belongs to him all of a sudden takamichi
kicks the gun out of kisaki's hand and
grabs her pointing at akisaki he tells
hisaki that it should have been him
holding the gun from the beginning
before telling kisaki to die takamichi
points a gun at kisaki prepared to shoot
as he believes he can save hina by
killing him just then hina and mikey
show up to the scene watakamichi briefly
distract by heinous shouts kisaki takes
this opportunity to run as takamichi
chases after him he tells kisaki that it
is over as no one will trust him anymore
when much kisaki responds saying that he
can start over again swearing to make
hina his someday takamichi says he will
not let that happen telling hisaki that
he will not even let him timely again
upon hearing this kisaki stops in the
middle of a crosswalk asking if
takamichi still thinks that he is a time
leaper takamichi is surprised by this
fact but before kisaki can explain a
truck crashes into him after he is
struck by the truck kisaki lays in the
intersection when he tried to get up his
mangled body prevented him from doing so
screaming at his agony and powerlessness
hisaki says that he does not want to die
as his body becomes motionless mikey and
hina catch up with mikey asking what
happened with kisaki's death the kanto
incident ends the remaining s-62 members
are arrested while the three deaths are
emasano izana kudakawa and tita kasaki
the participants of the kanto incident
are left to somberly reflect on the
events
so that there officially brings us to
the end of the tenjiku arc and well it's
an absolutely insane way to end an
awesome arc if you ask me be sure to
comment down below what your favorite or
saddest part of this arc was if it was
the death of emma izan or kasaki was at
the moment mikey showed up and professed
that he could take down 20 000 men if so
then be sure to let me know down in the
comment section below and as i said at
the beginning of the video this is
directly taken from my entire tokyo
adventures video explained so if you
want to find out what happens from here
on out then be sure to go and check out
that video which i will leave a link to
down below if not then don't worry as i
will be releasing the balancing part or
part 3 in the following weeks but anyway
enough of that if you have enjoyed the
video and want to keep up to date with
the latest tokyo avengers content and
just other anime content in general then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and also be sure to leave a like on the
video as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my stuff to a bunch
of new amazing people but anyway enough
of that for now it's been your
professional degenerate diavolo and i'll
see you all in a birth bye